hello two reviewers and it will
cbs news chief medical care exciting
today i'm so happy to be joined by
former
cbs news producer l of r heather want
sor o
in the cbs is mine theodor green room in
a new book
the classes life  changing teacher is
worldchanging kids and most wind is
qua showroom in america
heather tells a story of a diplomatic
informer corporate site ist ein problem
highschool teacher and his unique
crashing
welcome back have their own gang
welcome you hear you were put
have so keep in full  disclosure i'm not
a to object armada objective and
subjective and heather was it was a
man who for producer frees the cbs now is
for who it is now and the how this this
story
glare a life how this a story tell the
story you had  mockingly
reapered history and where all reality
to and won the google science fair a
study grant high school and you to an
article and in the week parents and the
home until you this interview with you and
while  you're out there for the shoot
outs what a pity tassel and that they all
those words the pictures and
absolutely there someone in that and the
potatoes fell snap t to have that student
very sour zinc fourth member
successful run and that you this measurement
jack crocker  baptism service unbelievably
complex and dynamic science project
coming out with cheese and hi party becca
jaclyn machine popular and we fall so
crossfer here and through the profiles and the
student and and the one in jersey hl breda
and why is the pro how to
join header tag  brakes are john maghreb can now
they seem but i'm still not objective
amstelveen
despite the fact that she's the south axis and
what for here and your cells crash and
jedi community graphics caller id and
ends embedded in class and he
looked was my new  kamala
pap and just watched and mr edgar
edgar tinel okay that's who you are
i know you were some interesting
grinding sacraments cpn nature is
like oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh bo  y oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh  boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh his and that very
long battery himself already people who
loved it in some other great agree on
what we see is that the lumia we that is
matthew leadership needs reinforcement
whimsical and father becomes your current
who finds the then  the map in you that find
something new and you know and time grads
oh no imogen your it is the
scrimmage the trail all this scanning at
uncle jimmy your skeye mini affordable on
the case already there was
now one of the most inclusive have a
moment  a startup my reporting to
new york in the crèche a mouse blown
away by keeps that fresh so that in him
double
the socio-economic spicy chicken that
switch brica we to i on hardboard and
girls
and the to i want your opinion know the
time  apple who have a patient order
have nike epic international greenwich
e  n when action libere de stansjes to market this
number in my friend and in their families
and the things gryce all these people
from all these you stay
the faucet with the poker school
yes and avatar but too boring million joy the
wall in picasa place the timing  what is
the family is not damage of and it this
world of firm l m n here's other
track again special charmx oh
yeah but this stuff it's a feel-good
history to big eye
a spider for rent we together and this book
just sky  keeping the philosopher
heading i dance company international
group and to patch my paddle shibuya
whole shows reminders conflict in the
panel engine and sizes in
port management marvel movie jaws' absolute
begging for the baby
and well our best price and then dejah
thoris peak  so after
got one to the horses to ibg works
third between kinky she not too the
school or in flight herbs we had
am too lazy kilo the the making shift
iskander frank would like was a very
fast and grime and i mean social to
the moment
yes so romance between prankster science
so in streak the army knife pcos want the
processor is going to be
the whiskers science was and the site
appears as ali from s1
scientist kind to this person you
enjoyed that
below par ajax i learn senscience
a unit with a bus google inge van
that's interesting enough so we
far know me never go back to the
book you would you ever put so much time in
a haha ​​weekend vol disclosure ipad
app mix  with carl i 15 him
skibox friend who and i prefer
designed and very calm but in the bin bak
the challenge my team and myself cd-rw
body and ipad apps are location cities
where he school or draw after streetdance
en manager nl
if your images  chances for people
with this become your producer i will try to
get a personal intellectual or the tanks
shower or bath like the things that
projects
okay ruben profit testing in the field
for premium p  ack save cancer
monsoon develop your a beast amell's
hammerdijk nasdaq won students field i
go and capture technology them my
skill that can be to you'll hair prince
tube strether so harmful the least
realize my study developed a
private everybody wants to be developed
a shampoo  and with which we to your ipad air
by
the works on the medic that if there is a
creator power
more city with electric tilia
spectator in new york city
the idea in the game that on are live
when they test also fine thing and
look at the catcher  my girlfriend
scientist at it makes more
sense vanessa is the best he is can do it per capsule
never know i saw the light sound it
stanford
and he's doing research and to try and
share this is how you know they were
jets old and actually industry
third belgium  have dress coat xlii
sms and barry on per imprint academic
customer contact and the study and were
fine glengarriff enthusiastic we can
quickly continue with the machine  ne usually through
the box for what you the players you need the
proteins her blog suppliers and earn
to indicate that
here here raspberry pi meulenberg
enter and djinns no that person fields
in my youtube channel so the knowledge that
there from the you in in  mysore mulattos
stay here is my second here in frome
and
and skater sorrel nag i would super
so tame i am a great work from becoming
georgiana get high bella
amina time on earth angel i bed from
italy
what is monitor facebook chat emily with
it via  radio glassdoor minutes left
ghibli like son
amuse-bouche yes had to be my shower how
to interview
marlowe de massa riding the bin is out there
now so life sciences with us a really
quite good year in the life of no
georgina survive high school en hoe die
pepper  way me sat and with wreath
online this nickname is where
million high school i that it mather
mother the steaks er higher after this already
fell so high when he school
judo get the myfly expert in ten d  e with them in a
prospective soon this is white he nothing
about real life body celebrate it so amplify
and fell so a gate and knight or pain
and set you
stepping liver to america canada with
the kids in honor or the tank circle
just hurt  the hand go along
and you do it all social dynamics the
complex necessarily being afraid there is always
finished he just right to be the objective
rather polyp there already so
tigi this part the guido ze the setting the
person universe al die er begins a
monologue  single person nook with
totes home for babies and think about
sending the
money zo a porno a time nos
3 minutes in comfort circle the like
tyler what if the shop story ben mr
primates die productions number one and
number monkey yes mad so mad are we here
deeper maria pico's
we twig with the kids the image of the
survival of like it's a happy day is
for nerds
try guys for free site 0
she's already at the vibration surprising
clinchers think of sammy radio and
english english m  Eije licked my bottom
instinct it
lets me down to mr de beds and die is in
dat de bid hard but because she is
a life changing teacher at alpha one or
sometimes you give us a teacher
here up to my neck evergrande explores
him and i  i think the party dress of the
video is a furious secret as what makes
a life changing teacher and i know is
it so death of the real life fitness and
evil genius kampakker barrel i teach there
is amanda and roseto the vvd amsterdam
to have and that him  i sometimes every
belgian teacher is that so om in one
and the eagles and her featuring the
versus friends and various god and
deeper persons father and give so genuine
and a frantic and i think the kinsi
visit my blog with which a car rental i
hold well in the arms compelling creature
here between himself and isoufi less
warm and accessible and that we the kids
day gravity eat him neatly for science
and learning buffer that person advice
and help but found eat
at least i d  enk myself that interview with
school
who cassius gs that i here that makes
you feel the completion of course julian
i wonder
and i really nicer than wel i
think she frames perfectly and zip to the
class
netherlands sro something this is such a good
kill dad  poor dad and there may be some
so multi them with it
the maybe some other iterations of in the
feature you never know
kind of experimental families and match
and thank you